so we're starting the very last bit of
material that we're recovering the
semester and we're looking at this
thinker Thomas Aquinas who I think maybe
some of you have encountered before
it certainly hurt bottom in history
classes but maybe actually read a little
bit of this material before depending on
where you went to school Catholic
circles but also important in he's
getting out wider importance and
Protestant circles strangely about today
Thomas is building off of Aristotle and
I don't know how much of the history to
know but you know he he was around at
the time when the Aristotle's works were
becoming available and Aristotle you
know you've been looking at his B's on
virtue and happiness and the point of
human existence that came as a sort of
revelation sort of pun intended to all
these Christian thinkers who up until
that time had been looking at things in
somewhat different ways Aristotle gave
me these these very fine analyses of you
know what makes me even being work what
is virtue whatever vices and so Thomas
wanted to bring together all of these
things you wanted to bring together all
the other Christians thought up until
this time and Aristotle and the reason
they did that is because you have this
basic idea that truth is truth and
whether it's coming from a distinctly
religious source or a philosophical
source if it's truth you want to take it
in and you want to try to do what with
it you want to try to synthesize it to
bring it together to make it all fit and
you got to do things like this in your
life right
I mean your whole college process has
been about taking all these different
things that you're learning from all
these different sources different
textbooks different classes totally
different disciplines and trying to
figure out what these have to do with
each other well how are these connected
with each other and not just you know
abstractly all right but in your life so
you guys go back to that McIntyre thing
you guys have all been graphically
certain kinds of questions
college students one of those big
questions is what does all this stuff
have to do with me
how does this connect me you know do I
have to act it one way over here think
one way over here and then think it's
totally different way over here can I
bring them together can I make them all
business so Travis is synthesizing
Aristotle in previous Christian thought
this quote of Terror is not by Saint
Thomas but it's by somebody else that
that Thomas drew on and it's one that I
think is particularly good for setting
the tone for this material I heard two
restless until they rest in you does
anybody know who who said that it's a
really famous passage you might have
come across
we're gonna be heads it was if some
Saint doesn't narrow it down that
doesn't help me say sir the Saint before
Thomas because Thomas actually wants it
another guy sort of a big heavy hitter
in moral theory obviously and what do
think he's talking about who's you yeah
and and one of the things that you find
in these these Christian thinkers to
looking at a Jewish thinkers Muslim
thinkers in new theaters theistic
Buddhist thinkers someone who does
actually are theistic is the sense that
there's something that transcends offs
there's something that transcends the
world that we can see it experience
something that's greater and so we
actually experience or are connected
with whatever it is it's greater we're
not going to be truly happy we're not
going to be truly satisfied that's
something that you're gonna see and say
Augustine we're gonna see that and
Thomas Aquinas you'll see that in most
religious thinkers and I want to sort of
get something out of the way at the
beginning oftentimes people will say
things like well ha you know you can't
bring religion into
thanks for religion and morality really
have nothing in common and you know
there's there some truth to the worries
that lie behind up but in point of fact
a lot of our moral theory has actually
come from for the distinctives and
through people who were involved in
religious practices and held religious
beliefs and that's still true today you
know Martin Luther King for example who
everybody wants to do is this great
exemplar for a lot of things he wouldn't
have done what he did I was a Baptist
minister and he hadn't studied not to
hate it just get up to the pulpit sir in
preaching he studied theology and he
read Thomas Aquinas they read st.
Augustine he was influenced by these
guys and there's this sense that as soon
as we start talking about religion it
becomes totally personal totally
subjective we can't bring anything any
of this stuff in that's not what these
thinkers and one thing I also want to
stress to you at the beginning of this
tune is we can study this no matter what
our religious beliefs are you can be an
atheist and study st. Thomas and get
what he's saying you're probably going
to disagree within those songs that's
right you can study st. Augustine and if
you're an atheist you think that then
you there isn't just God and that there
is no such thing then of course you're
going to disagree with st. Augustine but
you can at least understand what you say
and so that's what that's the sort of
approach that we're going to take the
test what I'm going to presume that
anybody can be particularly just
believed in this classroom not going to
make this about my own views for or
against things we're just going to try
to look at what Thomas is saying and try
to understand his perspective and as you
go through it one thing that you can see
that
is not doing he's not just simply
quoting by the passage incision he's not
just saying the Lord sayeth so therefore
shut up and do it
you know don't ask questions he's
actually exploring a lot of questions
and again this is something that you may
not associate with religion even if
you're a religious would be not
associating this with religion because
you may have had sort of of the sort of
shut up and the demon kind of variety
these great thinkers their view was God
gave human beings reason the capacity to
think something that elevated them above
the animals the other right and God also
put a designer again human beings this
is what we're going to talk about with
Thomas put a desire in human beings that
goes beyond the sort of things that we
have been talking about so far this
semester you know think about all the
different goods that we put on the table
so to speak you guys brought this up a
number of different times
what are these well pleasure you all
like pleasure
don't you anybody who doesn't you talked
about this Verrazano if you don't like
pleasure there's something actually
wrong with you probably wrong with your
body
maybe something hey we're the brain
right but the pleasure doesn't totally
satisfied us think about all the
pleasures that you experienced candy bar
candy bar tastes pretty good while
you're eating it doesn't it first might
taste better than the second blank
already it's starting to sort of decline
who's diminishing returns my name after
you've eaten it you might want another
candy bar because new you're no longer
having the candy bar and it works away
with many other pleasures to even the
intellectual pleasures like reading you
know you read a book you're reading
this is great it's amazing stuff how
much of that did you actually carry
around in your mind and retaining
afterwards you may actually have to go
back to the book sometimes don't you if
you really enjoyed it then start let's
start that book working again
what other goods well you know deeper
Goods
relationships lottery product ravans or
family can those totally satisfies some
people think that they can some people
think you know I'm going to get married
and I'm going to find the one and then
everything is going to be smooth and all
of my desires will be satisfied by this
is this person we think you know shows
but you guys have seen that sort of
thing - maybe somebody was experienced
which would be kind of early on actually
frankly speaking when you're you know 20
20 seems pretty pretty old right 22 22
seems pretty old some people actually do
but even then your life isn't completely
full what if that person turns out to be
bad or abusive or they get taken away
from and now you feel breathe it's not
being totally satisfied what if you see
that person working really really hard
and getting nothing out
what are other ways people people try to
pile off lots of money houses cars all
sorts of other material hoods to those
truly satisfied I mean think about the
things the physical things would be
desired recently I get this game can't
wait to play this game or what else if I
could just get that I love to have that
house Pinterest is sort of a big sport
Pinterest yeah some of those those words
I have titles like I want this you know
this is what I need or gotta have this
and you know what are they pictures own
sometimes it's the food food is consumed
like that right the whole player food
isn't consuming maybe looking at before
you actually did get houses places to go
on trips clothing some of it has to do
play a lot of it actually interest
things were people with all this this
wedding planning stuff into the
wedding's over very quickly none of
these things will truly satisfied
according to somebody like Augustine
what does he mean by Restless are hard
to arrest us they're not fully satisfied
they can't finish looking for things
even when they're enjoying something
there
to the science and what about that even
when they're enjoying save friendship or
a relationship with a person there
they're still thinking this isn't fully
yet there are restless until they
arrested in you Augustine he's a great
guy to read I don't know if any of you
have read his confessions Augustine
tried it all out
he's one of my favorite Saints in part
because he sinned so much and he he you
know said maybe pleasure is the good let
me try this out as much as I can and
then he got to the end of it and said
ìdonít that didn't work you know he
tried study he tried he actually joined
a cult fervor for some years just to try
to get answers about things he tried
relationships he tried all sorts of
other things until he found his solution
which was being connected with something
transcendent something that could truly
satisfy and what was this test for that
does it actually truly satisfy Augustine
is very experiential Thomas Aquinas is
less of Thomas Aquinas is much more
intellectual as you're reading through
this right you don't see an awful lot of
passion there an awful lot of well I
tried this and it didn't work for me
it's more it's more general isn't it so
I think that's a good frame of mind and
put yourself in thinking about this and
I don't actually want to start with the
first question in the reading that
Thomas addresses I actually want to skip
to the very last one in our reading for
today which is question five article
eight whether every person design
champions because that's really
fundamentalism now you notice that one
of the things that that Thomas does is
he doesn't just say okay here's a
question here's the answer okay we're
done let's go home
he actually considers other
possibilities doesn't he says the
objections he says not all those are
happiness nobody can desire what they
don't know so it's the apprehended good
is the object of the appetite but many
people don't know what happiness is this
is evident from the fact as Augustine
says some thought that he happiness
consistently is behind some in in virtue
of the soul some with other things
therefore not everybody desires
happiness if the happiness is really
some how God does everybody desire God
separately centered around God what's
your experience yeah everybody knows was
on fire for God it's many things if you
are religious you will often find
yourself
actually think about God at all today
you know if that's happiness and
everybody knows that that's happiness
then wouldn't we be desiring God all the
time we'd be like centering so you know
this is a real objection that's of
happiness isn't an all-new desire
happiness then shouldn't we all be doing
constantly Thomas knows that that's not
the case of notice he's writing in the
Middle Ages they call it the age of
faith people were just as given to
looking at other things and saying hey
God can wait for a little while at the
back that is there now they struggled
with the same sort of problems as we do
now just different forms so he says not
everybody desires happiness
what's another problem the essence of
happiness is the vision of the divine
essence but some considered impossible
for human beings to see the divine
essence so you can't see it you can't
desire I can hear you think about all
the different things that you didn't
desire when you were a kid that you do
now whatever what are some things that
you desire now now that you have tasted
well what's something you've experienced
here America
yeah yeah I think I don't think any of
you would be happy in going back to the
relationship of dependence that you had
a result yeah
I think if you actually experience the
life on your own maybe something
catastrophic happened but that would
anything else they have you been exposed
to any kinds of music that you haven't
heard you who and you love it
yeah music is one of those sort of
things we're just being provided an
intellectual description of it is not
kind you actually have to hear it and
then either it takes hold of you or it
doesn't and once it takes hold of you
you know what it's like to desired music
it's strong isn't it well you know if
happiness as Thomas says is seeing God
face-to-face seeing what God really is
how can any of us desire that can we
claim that we've seen God face to face
so if God is something sort of like
music you know you have a good country
music reporter they actually listen to
it you're not gonna just layer then
maybe we don't desire that either and if
that's happiness maybe we don't lecture
deserve competence but he says this is
another interesting one Augustine says
that happy is he who has all the desires
and desires nothing amiss but all the
not desire this for some desires certain
things amiss and yet they wish to desire
such things so not everybody desires
champions now I guess that's not a term
that we use often to me is anything
amiss with you well how do we say that
our dads anything wrong
are you okay do people sometimes like
things to be screwed up
and that's a good way to describe it
some people enjoy generating situations
in which they get to act as replies I
guess that's what we mean by your honor
I want them it involves conflict right
and conflict is not a good thing by
itself some people enjoy being unhappy I
mean there's one thing yeah somebody
close to you dies now you've grieved for
a while and you feel sad and people
trying to cheer you off but it doesn't
really help that much that's normal
right to be grieving about it many years
later in the same way that would be kind
of pathological sometimes we desire
things that are bad for us okay
and we know that they're bad for us
we're still desired sometimes people can
get caught in a cycle where they they
desire things that are bad for them and
then they feel bad about that and then
to make them feeling you know bad about
themselves go away they want those
things that are bad for them and it just
keeps reinforcing itself obviously is
putting this out there Thomas is greater
so using my mistake some people actually
do designer things to be screwed up so
can we say that everybody actually does
does that our happiness let's look at it
as as response it says I'd answer that
happiness can be considered two ways
first according to the general notion of
happiness a must of necessity
everybody designers have this general
notion when you talk about having a
general notion of something that means
that you can apply to a lot of different
things and you can't necessarily pin it
down before you came here to the mayor
and Santa classes semester after
semester and you know I have a lot of
different professors you had sort of a
general notion of what college is going
to be like you say that how did you
picture probably is something a kind of
like high school but different different
in what way
who knows they're gonna actually got to
show off but then you find out right now
how many classes of you guys think this
is for most of you at the end of your
junior year that you're taking on
average five classes a semester so you
guys have taken my 30 classes so I'm
gonna be more into summer classes or
classes pretty good handle on what
college classes are like you have a very
specific don't you don't you as opposed
to a general notion so yourself Hamas's
we often have general notions so all of
us desire happiness and an sense
remember we were looking at air so that
all of us desire happiness we're all
seeking it and then aerosol says okay
what is it that what is happiness
so then it says the general notion of
happiness consists in the perfect good
whatever it is that we think is going to
fix our lives whatever we think it is is
going to satisfy us whatever we think it
is is that goal out there that we're
reaching for that's happiness for us so
happiness for me may not be exactly the
same as happiness for you and then you
probably differ about it and you change
things from day to day as you've gotten
older you've gotten more definite notion
of happiness haven't you
okay and then he says since good is the
object of the will perfect good of a
person is that which entirely satisfies
your well so it is up to designer
happiness is nothing else that desire
that ones will be satisfied and can we
have different notions of this different
understandings of what it will be to be
satisfied
you got a drawer papers about this right
the journal do you think I just needed
to read one to know what my students
think you know yours may be just stood
in for all of the rest I have read your
paper in order to read anybody else's
well we all have very different
consumptions don't and he says we can
also speak of happiness according to its
specific notion as they act to which
this to that in which it actually does
consist and thus all do not know
happiness because they don't know in
what thing the general notion of
happiness is fun so in one sense we all
do desire happiness we all pursue it
because we all have our own pictures of
it we all have our own images of it but
if what will make us truly happy is
actually this and you're not pursuing
that you're not desiring it then you're
not desiring
what will in fact make you happier
desire something think is gonna make you
like success for example all of us do
desires success I still do myself you
know when I publish an article makes me
feel good you know somebody says come
get a talk here it makes me feel good
that's something I do desire it
student evaluations you know pretty
small on the scale admittedly but if I
get good evaluations you know that's
kind of a success if I wrap my life
around there
correct my life to that and said this am
I truly going to be happening no I'm not
truly pursuing what will make me not
pursuing happiness itself I'm pursuing
something that's popular yeah that quote
could you also explain that as like an
inner peace like knowing that I know is
because your happiness often times is
like when someone just realizes like
when you're talking about people can't
be happy because usually it's cuz they
don't look at the good things but they
just look at what's wrong whatever sick
yeah so what that also be like you
realize you have everything even if it's
not everything you know yeah if you read
Augustine and a lot of other religious
thinkers you'll see them talking in very
similar terms to what you're bringing up
there's there's sort of desiring God as
yeah and then there's desiring a
relationship with God and part of that
relationship when you see this very
clearly in Jewish and Christian as being
okay with how things really are rather
than saying I believe in you've got but
you're such an awful God look all this
crap that you put me in right that's
that's not the sort of relationship with
God that these rules makers first
although as a possibility ISM you don't
believe in God and hate God be angry
with God totally unsatisfied with your
condition to be at peace would mean
something like saying well you know this
isn't everything that I wanted but maybe
this is actually the best thing for me
maybe I have to learn how to appreciate
what I've got and then you're right
people
peace and you could read what he was
saying as best as this piece exactly
right let's look at some of his replies
to these objections he says sometimes
you know we we desire something in one
way but not in another so when we what
we truly desire is that you know seeing
God face-to-face oh that's what we're
most satisfies is that none of us tend
to think in these terms
day to day even those of us who are
religious don't think you know divine
essence all the time this isn't
happiness may be considered is the final
perfect good which is the general notion
of happiness and the will naturally
tends towards that but it can be
considered under special aspects and
then under these sort of things what
what do we think will make us happy what
do we actually start pushing ourselves
towards what do we choose to pursue what
do we choose to place highest in our
ranking values that's not necessarily
going to be done as a matter of fact
that may take a lot of work you know
being at peace takes a lot of work
doesn't it you want to ask actually
you can't just stand all right inner
peace there was a great episode of
Seinfeld kind of all the show down where
the characters got into this kind of
cult-like thing and he would just say to
himself serenity now serenity now
whenever you get into a conflict that
sort of situation where you feel bad and
of course by the end of the episode the
episodes are only you know like what 26
minutes he's already fuming and angry
that's not working you can't just say to
yourself okay I can be at peace it would
take some work it takes some development
using the will the modding meit's to
steer your house towards that let's look
at the third objection sometimes people
want things that screw it up
sometimes people want it to be
themselves screwed up so doesn't that
just prove that the idea that all is
learnt happens maybe some people really
desire to be misery Thomas says when it
comes down to it he says if we
understand happiness to be those things
that human beings desire according to
their apprehension of reason it doesn't
belong to happiness to have certain
things that they desire rather it
belongs to unhappiness
insofar as the possession of such things
hinders the person from me having all
that they actually do desire so this is
a little bit tricky to think of that
when somebody wants to be unhappy you
know and you know people like this right
why do they want to be unhappy what is
going on with them there's a lot of
different possibilities
some damaging event to the life service
to them on the wrong course and now they
want to stick to what we feel safe for
them or we talking about that cycle or
somebody desired something that's bad
for them and they pursue it they enjoy
it now they feel bad about themselves
and to cover up that you can think of
relationships using drugs they can be a
person you know being very
confrontational
that's not going to be happy ism
Thomas says those people they actually
still do desire happiness but something
is kind of screwed up they're pursuing
something that will make them happy in a
certain way it'll satisfy the center in
the short-term but it's actually setting
up roadblocks he doesn't use this term I
think this is a good way to think of it
it sets up roadblocks to what would
actually make them happy ultimately it
may actually even set up roadblocks to
those sort of earthly goods if you're a
beam person because you kind of like
being a mean person
are you depriving yourself of some some
other goods that people you know these
were Thomas Aquinas say Harris all
thought were important for happiness and
what relationships can you be a really
you know mean person a jerk to everybody
else and have good relationships
you guys have been on the front of that
right you an anchor on somebody who's
sour all the time and criticizing you
there's some people you actually can't
have a good relationship right does that
mean that they don't desire
relationships at all right
maybe they desire it but they desire it
on their terms
sort of unrealistic way some way that
can't be realized
so let's look at some of these goods
that are actually desired that is that
people do think happiness consistent and
Thomas talks about three different kinds
of bills one behind you cause extra four
different kinds of it because God is
good with this traditional
Asli external goods is once an eclipse
and one who is a consistent probably
what's the most external good so yeah
what would you say the one that is least
attached to you
totally replaceable yeah about these
yeah one of these is just as good as any
other one that's a little point of money
isn't it yeah it sounded like you'd say
oh this this one's worth - because it's
wrinkled just the right way and I can
give this to any one of you and it's no
longer part yeah it's no longer part of
my possessions and it doesn't really
have any connection with me at all I
know some people do things like it write
things on the dollar bills you're gonna
try to get a message job and that kind
of personalizes would have been but one
dollar bill is pretty much like they're
nice and it works for any sort of well
you know when is your stock it's pretty
much like the next share of stock what
about other possessions others
everybody close I don't think there's a
single one of you in here whose clothes
would fit me right so your your clothes
are much better good for you than they
are for me you get attached to them kind
of like this time it's part of my stuff
but is it really in that connected with
me when I can take this down a good well
good night for all you know I may have
gotten it
those aren't really that connected with
us there are other kinds of external
visit our possessions things that come
to us from the outside and we like they
make us feel good we desire yeah
relationships with other people
an interesting thing Tomas is not going
to talk about like friendship or family
relations in this discussion although I
think that's pretty important he talks
about things like things you know you
turn heads right you you do desire
people to look up to you don't you you
want me to think well whether they
whether they're friends with you or not
you want
you know you don't want bad repute some
of you probably would like to be
successful not only in the sense of
having a lot of nice things not only in
the more rewarding sense of gonna
feeling like you could actually
accomplish something worthwhile but they
actually have people saying yeah you
made it you did a good job
might come from a family though right
oftentimes we measure success in terms
of whether mom or dad in pleased with
what we've done particularly for a
first-generation college students do
right graduating is going to be a big
big event what else
power another relationship we have the
people externally is power getting to
tell somebody to do something getting to
make them do what we want defending them
it's very well this can be as trivial as
you know going at the restaurant and
ordering the waiter to them were as big
as being the CEO of a corporation the
presidents of the country anything you
know we got great power and you
sometimes kind of life and death people
those are all he says external is where
the interesting thing about power is if
somebody is not building that power well
you could replace it with somebody else
can't you power is something that can
you can have and it can disappear like
that external goods can go away very
quickly can your reputation go very
quickly they can take just one bad email
you know one one person recording you on
their phone and it goes up to YouTube
suddenly you're a pariah you guys
remember just a little while back five
years back and the Seinfeld
cranber-- got myself in trouble
somebody was heckling him and they got
into the Hargitay event and then he
started throwing out all these these
racial slurs that destroyed his
reputation overnight because I didn't
want to fight all right but things could
happen like that what else what are some
things that are less easily taken away
aren't there Goods of your body that you
desire let's sort of bottom of next year
or some sort of modeling conditions to
you yeah yeah that's that's pretty
important isn't it look beyond
particularly when you feel sick there's
you know all the other stuff can't goes
out the window doesn't it oh I can just
get better I'll be such a good person
I'll never do anything wrong again
you're saying this is my greatest desire
just not to be clapping or not
health is pretty important are there
other bodily things that we desire
remote looks I mean think about how much
time and energy and money we put into
our appearances you know people actually
need to shower every single day
Danelle thing they're not gonna
necessarily get sick we have to put as
many things in here as we move or on
skin when you know utilitarian clothing
be better than you know jacket at a time
they moved all on the same uniform that
make things really simple for us for
maybe you know I should just have like
you know like olive oil and all that
that character she opens the closet
that's all a bunch of the same dress the
same skirt maybe I should just have this
outfit you know seven times and just
keep wearing the same thing why did we
care about you know fashion design
majors and art majors why is it so
important why do we care
these celebrity photos were taken in a
bad light there's this famous one with
Nick Nolte as his mug shot
he looks just insane where are you yeah
that's another important thing too we
and that's a bit more on connected with
who we are we want to portray a kind of
self image and they put a lot of work I
mean if you're working out in part
because you want to be healthy that's
one designer right if you're working out
because you want to have an attractive
body that's another thing that has to do
with sexual pleasure
if you're working out because you you're
really interested to see how there is
bodies and external bits
some people Thomas talks about the soul
no pleasure is interesting Thomas thinks
that pleasures include both the body and
the soul some of our pleasures and
pleasures of the smaller the pleasures
that you actually take in your friends
that's a pleasure
but there could be some pleasures in
volleyball like you play sports with
them right that's that's physical
activity that feels good but the feeling
that you have with them even the feeling
of about being on the same team that's
something that you have what are other
goods with so what are other things now
what - by the way that we're getting to
the things that are much harder to take
away things that are much more who you
are what other than goods of the soul so
you've been experienced yes exactly
virtues our visible vices are our evils
are bands as a virtue like Eric stone
says it's something that allows us to do
our environment job well and we don't
just have jobs like you guys have a job
as a student I have a job is professor I
can hold my job as a husband some of you
from their jobs as boyfriends
girlfriends but do you have a job
overall both all-encompassing job
function as Aristotle thinks you do
Thomas think city you do and those
virtues are what allow you to do that
well they allow you to be a good person
good in the broad sense not just good as
a student could as a professor good as a
comedian you know good as a coffee maker
but good as a human being
the virtues allow you to do that that's
very important and they're not names
will be taken away remember back when
you
virtues in your vices those of you who
many we talked about courage do you
actually have courage and you actually
have that as a part of your personality
not was going to take that away you know
those in terms of but there's there's a
good regardless really well that's
interesting
Thomas also doesn't talk about that but
yeah the experiences that you can that
make you who you are you know in a lot
of cases we might think of those as
being about the body but the body had
those experiences and now they're where
do they exist they exist in you remember
so people that you've encountered and
had talks with who influenced you the
places that you've been the things that
you've seen all those sort of things
that have changed you and made you think
about things and made you feel certain
things that got to the very roots of who
you are maybe actually shook you or
changed you in that process chemicals or
goods in the soil
and very often we associate who we are
with our memories if you look at all
this sort of science fiction intended
movies they're what's really you your
memories are an important part of what
else now we're getting to something very
very close to another great good side of
doing yourself learning things about
yourself what are you really
yes knowledge knowledge skills
intellectual dispositions are you gets
better researchers now after three years
is that just a matter of like having
kind of a list of things to do or is
that part of who you are now what do you
think if I give you an assignment like
like I did with the paper for this
semester may give you assignment and I'm
not going to do this let's say I gave an
assignment today and I said I want you
to go to the library and I want you to
find this quote by Augustine and tell me
what the context is and then find three
other authors after Augustine who quote
this I think you could do it couldn't
you do you think you would feel as
confident about that when you first came
in here three years ago maybe if you
know could you tell somebody else very
quickly just on the spot exactly how to
go do that research or is it more
something that you now can know within
you it's part of the fabric of what you
do
could you make a list right now if I
asked you to do that how to solve that
that particular research problem or
would it be easier to take somebody over
to the library and then guide them
around and then when they ask you
questions like why are we living over
here that answer
if that's the case and then you have
developed with Thomas and Aristotle call
and intellectually happens an
intellectual virtue he doesn't talk
about the other things once in your head
the same thing why don't we just hire
the textbooks that said of hiring a
computer why should we hire you
employers well they don't ask you things
like this what do you actually bring to
the table and I think that you can
actually point to thanks in each of your
fields you have a lot of different
fields here you know and I for being
able to tell what is likely to be
pleasing to other people's sensibilities
you know what's likely to be able to be
marketed and how to do somebody an
education here yeah okay that's that's
one which it involves a lot of
intellectual skills so these are all
good to the soul
don't people pursue all these things as
if they are the good kind of happiness
Thomas says that's kind of a mistake and
he tells me these questions why these
are particular interstates
what's what's wrong with that point of
view so let's look just at the first one
having to do it well he asked couldn't
happiness be well I mean there's
something to that doesn't matter we do
need wealth to be happy Aristotle says
ya can't wealth by us all the other
things that make us happy they should
solve them shouldn't we try to go out
there and make a ton of money first and
then we can worry about what's gonna
make us happy once we've got the money
that we can buy those things with no
sure you can pay people to follow you
around and talk to you about it frankly
we're not really your friends right
because as soon as you put down we
talked about this they're slowly
disappear can you buy somebody else's
love you know romantic involvement you
can pay me to have sex with you know
rope around you can't make them fall in
love with you Mike
well $10,000 didn't kind of let me get
another you know five goats daddy love
me another doesn't anybody help you you
can change your appearance catch it like
that plastic surgery there's limits to
what that could do
I mean money is not particularly
effective be as a means to happiness
unless you're actually putting your
attention somewhere else and cultivating
what we call the transit risk think
about the things that you guys are
studying
the Animus skills and knowledge that you
can't have talked about is a good at
soul can you buy them I don't mean in
the sense of somebody else paying you to
do the same thing for them what they're
doing retired right can they literally
buy that knowledge out of your head can
any amount of money do that the best
they can do is hire you they can't they
can't put that in their head so lady
says when it comes to well there's two
kinds of all Thomas princess says
there's natural wealth and this is
wealth let's talk for the sake of
something else as a supportive human
nature you know what does he mean by
that
things like food drink clothing our cars
transportation well that smaller that's
important but that isn't really
happiness those are the means that we
need for happiness
you're probably them a harder time being
happy if you're homeless
so shelter isn't right you're probably
gonna have a harder time in our society
if you don't have a car right unless you
live in the city you can take a subway
if you don't have food and drink you're
gonna have a really rough time right yet
we die we have your clothing you also
need clothing and clothing can be
comfortable or uncomfortable activities
you know pleasing to the eye or not
pleasing to the eye that is something
that's important but that won't make us
true the enemy lynnie also talks about
artificial wealth and it says artificial
wealth is that which is not a direct up
to nature like money boring or what else
comes with money in our society it
stocks
real-estate anything you would invest in
just just to make money what are some
other examples mom's book a fixed-rate
fluctuating like stocks do you get the
idea right these things are not even the
things that will buy themselves support
we're using agent without like food or
drink or clothing
there are pure meetings but even that
isn't going to make its County all we're
doing parents we're looking at the realm
of external goods so that's where where
we'll end and my next class session on
the pickup with the app so we have three
different kinds of goods external goods
good to the body goods of the soul and
its promises going to explore each one
of these has a potential candidate for
happiness because people do in fact want
them to think that these things are
happiness they are what will satisfy
them they are what they can find rest in
Thomas says that when you're fully
satisfied desired rest for will rests in
the good that desire so if you thought
would know that wealth would actually
make you can be the tester that would be
go out there and make a ton of money or
accumulate a lot of possessions and then
see if you're actually happy oh and if
you don't wanna do this yourself how
else could you do this look at other
people watch what they do see whether
making a lot of money or accumulating
possessions makes them happy if you
think that power is what makes people
happy like think back to through
Symmachus right
Aristarchus just wanted to be in charge
you said you got a team power that's the
best thing because once you get power
you get to do what you want well you
know you could actually do that yourself
or you could look at other people who
had power and see whether they're really
happy or not
so Thomas is doing
like this very similar to what Arizona
goes to it and similar to what other
people and converse you out those too so
let's look at that the first external
good well Thomas says there's really two
kinds of well there is what he calls
natural wealth and then there's
artificial level and these are in terms
that are a little bit strange for us
because we would think of natural wealth
as things like you know maybe the land
what he means are the things that serve
our our needs particularly our bottle
ashes so so what are those what do we
actually have together there drink yet
air he doesn't like what the air I think
you sort of takes that for granted but
he didn't have a problem with pollution
and those are absolute bare necessities
lacking those you're gonna die no
happiness after death the end of the
story what else he talks about clothing
shelter it's very difficult to be happy
if you're homeless in any full sense of
the term there are other part because of
dangers and freedom what else we talked
about cars or transportation
we need that don't we it's interesting
to see somebody in the medieval times
talking about transportation
they just stayed in the same place I've
never done anything and then Thomas was
from Italy and they actually spent his
time his adult life for the most part
teaching in Paris sort like an immigrant
being somewhere else what else well
these are things that we need for our
body for our lifestyle so what other
kinds of also we miss them new couples
things possessions right this is my
possession your shirt is your possession
that umbrella is your possession what
are other things that's a different kind
of good we wouldn't think of a
friendship as well is something in some
ways more permanent or you know what do
you do
give me a hint
you know every two weeks you should
probably get some of this when you're
working money yeah well if the primary
type of wealth is money but if you know
consists of other things too like real
estate stocks and bonds other things
which stand in for money or are supposed
to produce money right bank accounts
bank accounts contain money now can
accumulating a ton of money be happiness
well let's think this through let's sort
of try to be as sympathetic to that view
as possible lots of time as your device
maybe what you ought to do is go out and
make a ton of money and you know do that
until you say 40 years old
and if you do that and you you know you
take every opportunity
and we're really hard you could probably
be not just a millionaire but a
multi-millionaire by the time you're 40
and then can't you just take the rest of
your life another four years and really
enjoy yourself with that one do all the
things that you would like to do can't
buy you everything that you need I know
other people that like they work for a
long time and then like that finally
done like a lot of cops do you say yeah
and they just do they work more just
because you can people do it at the
retirement to do anything because money
you can't buy it can immediately money
you can't really it's other things it's
a means to things that might be our
comfortable way yeah yeah
can you let's say you've screwed up your
relationships because we didn't have any
relationships cuz you put all your time
into your work you worked 80 90 hours a
week now it's time now you're gonna
solve that and get serious or maybe them
to start David you're like 20 years of
practice right
it's gonna be kind of hard and can you
just go around saying I really want
somebody to make me happy and looking
for not just somebody to do things with
companionship not just not just sex but
also intimacy
I'll pay you $50,000 for that don't work
I mean you can buy yourself you know
trophy wife or trophy husband movies
those are not usually happy marriages
are they there are some but if they are
happy it's not because of the money
this is not to say that money isn't a
good thing right it is important for us
matter if X some other virtues have to
do with how we operate money what about
all those other things sometimes people
say well I need a ton of money but I
need I need the things that will allow
me to live a fairly simple life nice
house nice car and a reliable car is
that to be fancy or anything like that
but you know something that'll give me
peace of mind I'd like to have gardens
so that I can grow my big things just
like so like like it makes your name
bigger ah we're gonna get to that
yeah that's being reputation like like I
really like we've set up at the garden
like pants or something that like really
makes you happy on the inside then I
guess some people have the view that
they can accumulate enough material
things now they're going to be happy but
you know Thomas points out what's the
point of having these extra of goods so
that they could serve body and the soul
so they have a value not really in
themselves but they're valuable for
something else that something else is
where happiness is kind of why the other
thing that he points out that I think is
really interesting in here here is he
talked about money and he says three
things in these responses it says all
material things obey money so far as the
multitude of fools are concerned no
other don't know other than material
goods which can be obtained for money
but we should take our estimation of
human goods not from the foolish but
from the wise just as it is for a person
whose sense of taste is in good order to
judge whether thing is palatable if you
go up to the culinary and you want to
know whether you
this dish made by this this person or
that dish made by that person yes
somebody who knows food water right
don't ask somebody who who has you know
terrible taste in food so I just like to
eat macaroni and cheese all the time
that's good
everything else that's not macaroni and
cheese nobody there not a good show how
did you write similar that you wouldn't
you wouldn't actually take somebody who
says yeah anything that you need you
could buy the money that's a good job
yeah just by saying that they're kind of
shorting my sauces
the second thing he says is all things
saleable can be had for money true right
you get to go here for free somebody to
pay I mean even if you're here on
scholarship that's the school paying
itself or somebody else pay the school
ahead of time but somebody's getting
paid and you know that good of the sole
education is not by itself
well it's something more permanent isn't
it but you can buy at least the
opportunity to engage in it of course
it's not enough just for you to get in
here is it you actually have to work
final exams now you're actually fully
conscious once again in the semester of
just how much is on your shoulders
other things that can't be extra money
Thomas says not so spiritual things
which cannot be sold what do you think
he's talking about their relationship so
like friends family you know their
relationship because you can't have
somebody be your friend anticipated
you got money and you know yeah you can
get sort of the shells of full
relationships by buying people you know
dinner taking them places buying the
nice things you just like straight up
paying 50 bucks hang out yeah
comic we said earlier like there could
be the like like somebody marries for
well yes but their man for the wealth
for love
yeah you know there's actually an old
adage about that too when you marry for
wealth you have to earn it
yeah you have to give away things
yourself put up with so unhappiness but
like I said you won't you're only buying
the shovel the relationship you're not
actually buying currently you can't buy
the intimacy you can't buy the having
been in somebody's family member you go
to Kenya these things that just sort of
happen to you can you buy a relationship
with something transcendent Thomas
thinks that God is good can you buy a
relationship with God maybe there's
websites out there things like that do
you think they're actually we're sending
the money in - probably not
can you buy even knowledge by itself you
can buy your books that contain
knowledge can you buy the disposition
that you guys have knowing what it is
that you do being able to act on that
knowledge I can't do that the last thing
that he says it's really
so the desire for natural riches is not
infinite because they suffice to nature
in a certain measure then so I mean you
can get obsessed with shoes and fill up
a whole closet of shoes we really
consider that pathological right you
guys have seen those people do that
sometimes with clothing nice clothing
food and drink can we can we can of
orders with that - yeah look at some
people's wine cellars they use kind of
abusing most of it of giving some of
them away to charity that's not the word
for a time but there's there's an
alternate purpose - the horror shows are
different in that these people are just
accumulating this stuff and they think
that that's going to make them happy so
on the extreme coupon shows they're
using it as a means for happiness with
the order shows they think the material
goods are can give them happiness but
for most people they're sort of the
natural limits of this you need five
houses how many houses gonna live it
that's one you know I mean you could
have a summer house somewhere but it's
not much good you unless you actually
spend the summer there
how many cars TV well this one I mean
you can have 30 cars out the front yard
probably should spend money on building
a parking lot right rear garage but you
can only spend so much time and then you
get in the car even food right you can
only eat so many steaks or Sundays or
whatever what about our official well
the designer for that like he says is
infinite for it's the servant of
disordered designer
kakuka sense which is not curved the
desire for wealth can the desire for
money can become larger and larger and
larger and that's why you see that
people who actually Center the lines
around money don't usually look that no
matter how much they make this is what
it means to say that it's no matter how
much they make you can always imagine a
bit more whereas I think many of us
could actually be fairly happy with a
certain amount of possessions you could
probably be happier than one house a
nice house right probably be happy with
one decent reliable car you probably if
you wear suits and ties you probably
don't need 50 pair or 50 sets maybe
seven let's move on that what about
other external debts he talks about
honors this can honor being honored by
other people nominate to what you were
talking about being under bad that
people can that in that be be happiness
that's probably higher than just
possessions isn't it it's in some way
more dignified more noble and
what do you have if you want to be
honored what do you actually have to do
yeah and you have to have some sort of
qualities that people actually like
otherwise they're not going to honor you
you have to like I said you have to put
in work time and effort maybe good money
they're good to make sacrifices but you
actually did something worth honor in
yourself but if that's the case Thomas
says it's not the honor by itself that
happiness consistent that's what you're
being honored on account of this time so
if you're being honored because you're a
particularly generous person the honor
itself is not going to make you happy if
you're really generous you're generous
because you recognize that is the right
thing to do and you like it that way and
you see that as an important thing to do
and you would do it even if other people
weren't honoring wouldn't you and that's
the test to see whether somebody really
has that quality do they act like that
even when nobody else is watching
generosity be a good example from these
benefactors who don't make a big deal of
themselves and hide the fact that
they're giving things away they're not
looking for honor are they so honor
itself probably can't be happiness
either Lee says they can result from
happiness but happiness cannot
consistently what about another kind of
thing related to fame or glory or as we
would say celebrity being in the
spotlight
don't people
they're finishing at 15 minutes of pain
once we get that 15 minutes probably not
enough though all right you know this is
a really interesting one because in all
the professions that you're going into
there are going to be temptations all
you want success and that that's that's
good that you want success I'm glad that
you don't want to be a failure you know
because then we'd have different issues
to talk about but success by itself
people will often come to take that as
the measure for whether their life is
full whether it's complete they think
that being successful will satisfy them
and they measure that success not by
what they actually accomplish but what
other people think they accomplish by
how other people see them by their
titles or you know I mean you can
actually change it around go a corporate
business thing bohemian there's all
different ways to do this I kind of
think and I'd be interested to get your
take at us I kind of think that the
whole hipster phenomena revolves around
this this wanting to be distinctive and
have other people see just how
distinctive you are you know because
you're you're drinking you know
I mean does this sound right do you
think that could be along these lines
those people think that that lifestyle
we're just sort of seeking a kind of I
think we're all at a very young age and
only through the media we're all taught
to seek Fame that's understandable that
people may act in a certain way to bring
attention to themselves or bring about
pain and it is very true that sometimes
people want to act differently or be
different just for the sake of getting
attention rather than that's their
actual personality yeah right basically
they by doing those things that are
different they're attracting attention
to themselves
okay wait attention that they're doing
so in a very contentious way right and
you know there are lots of other ways to
do that trying to himself just by itself
if the whole goal of excelling is to
have other can look at me and say wow
that person
or great player of this game now Thomas
says that can't be are are true good
says favorite glory is actually false in
a certain way it's less than because
under at least requires that we have
something good about you right can
people have all sorts of fame or glory
or you know crazy things that really
don't have much to do with good
character or happiness what are some
examples of that yeah I think you're
right
reality TV shows as a phenomenon have
made all sorts of people or the famous
by just putting on the front of the
camera somehow and yet we're drawing and
watching them that worries the first
person I always think of money together
as a pair of story famous for being
famous right it's just not just that
help step well - that's not a video
oh yeah yeah or think about some of the
people that are famous less for good
things and bad things and sometimes it
you know the perception of that could
change over time right who's probably
the most famous bad
I'm gonna be close even in his day a lot
of people recognized himself a genuinely
terrible person right but how did he
actually end up getting power a lot of
people thought he was actually a really
great person and they wanted him to be
in power yeah he had to sort of you know
fame and glory and you can actually see
this working as he's writing about
himself in his own writings you know
puffing up the image might say yeah fame
and glory can change rapidly over time
it's not a good measure happiness it's
not a good measure of anything that
would consist in Hamptons he says if you
actually think about it and again it's
the bring in God if you think about
God's knowledge and you compare that to
human knowledge how well do we actually
know the goodness or badness of people
compared to delude by its own
relationships or passions or assumptions
or partial effects if they're if Gloria
was actually going to be something good
Thomas Aquinas so he rejects that as a
candidate for happiness now he gets the
most interesting extra what about power
amazing you know well there's nothing
compared to power right being able to
control other people being able to tell
them what to do and make them bend into
your will is really interesting I
actually shopes are actually pretty
pretty faithful about the possible
market is really interesting in part
because because his world is very
versatil I actually did a presentation
on this recently that I videotaped or
popular culture Association yeah it's a
lot of other people were sort of making
that connection as well you see people
seeking power as how many everybody
watched me of that came across it's in a
fantasy world there's all these noble
houses they're all trying to control the
kingdom they all have a lot of history
with each other a lot of bad blood
between each other and so there's all
this lying around and the Alliance
making and wars going on and sometimes
you can't tell who's good people trade
ultimately it's about who controls the
Iron Throne which is made of swords
nice thing to say actually people get
cuts I think that but why do they want
to do that because of the power balls
yeah they kill each other and they
torture each other and they buy you know
allies against each other and scheme and
plot and engage in all sorts of things
and there are actually some morally good
people in the series but not many that
to me most of them are actually either
different or actually genuinely bad and
some of the ones who are the most
genuinely bad are the ones who are
seeking power so it's an interesting
candidate because people will often do
think that happiness rests in cannon
power they'd rather be powerful and
wealthy they'd rather be powerful than
good rather than powerful the ones and
why
well can't however give you everything
that you want
imagine you were the made the president
right now I'm let's say there were no
you know there was no Congress to get in
the way or Supreme Court matter fellas
later president dictator for life
they make you dictator for life you're
Stalin you had a lot of power
now Stalin's and interesting get one
second then what happened was thought he
had absolute power
at least with didn't in Russia did it
make him happy what happened to he
became incredibly paranoid one of the
things that the power is you know it's
easy to grab it's also very easy to lose
to us now and if you act like somebody
who wants power you actually tend to
foment other people underneath you try
to get that power as well so you can
never really trust them he didn't have
any good relationships he could do
anything that he wanted but his life
became kind of empty
came from because they guys became the
beginning the only ones in the world
yeah Robert he wants other city like
Felix eating a lot he likes
so he's like this she's totally Thomas
says it's impossible for happiness to
the consistent power first because power
is the nature of principle whereas
happiness as the nature of last event so
power is something that lets us get
things done but it's not ultimately the
thing that we're desiring the last the
final he says secondly because of power
has relation of good and evil
whereas man's happiness in a proper and
perfect good so happiness rather than is
evil or you can use your power well what
would determine whether or not other
people that's actually the view of power
that most people that get absolute are
those that are seeking it and usually
that are good do not want absolute they
want power to be shared rather than
somebody that's bad they want to have
absolute power and they want to utilize
it to get whatever it is they want all
right like maybe five six years ago I
was reading like Machiavelli book and
the prince oh yeah oh my god he said
differently no it was the prince it was
the prince yeah it was interesting yeah
yeah he's pretty he's pretty upfront
about you was mentioning like is it
better to be loved
you know what's the best way to go about
ruling it well all this makes the next
Thomas power if it's going to be used
well it's going to have to find some
other good that happiness done may be
consistent so let's let's talk now about
bottling this what are the things that
we consider to be goods of the body that
actually belong to us much more and
power does or possessions do or
reputation
what's the very first thing good health
yeah everybody comes up with that
because it really isn't when you don't
feel well the world looks very different
when you're sick the only thing you
actually desire medicine there's other
things though appearance appearance can
that be the good for us
Thomas says something really interesting
he says it's impossible for man's
happiness to consist in the goods of the
body and this for two reasons he says
the first one is if the things are
gained to another as to its end its last
end cannot consist of the preservation
of its being because what does that mean
that that's that's kind of hard to wrap
your head around let me read it to you
if the things were gained or ordered to
another as it said one thing is worded
to another thing as as the end of that
thing it's last and cannot good system
the preservation of its being he gives
you an example the captain does not
intend as
last and the preservation of the ship
entrusted to him why not because the
ship is for getting pension love
question your bodies like that your body
is not the be-all and end-all of your
existence it is for some people the
promises there are very sorely mistaken
your body is something that lets you get
around and experience that let's use an
example with sexuality and intimacy why
do people get married lots of reasons
it's pregnant better get married
appearances but all you know what's the
main reason why people get married yeah
yeah they want a lifelong partner and
there's definitely a physical elements
made a lifelong companion but also sex
isn't of all otherwise don't get married
just hang out with the person you know
no necessity they have what if older
times is called a Mariana launched a
marriage the point of marriage is
actually to be involved sexually and
then the companionship arises
and then what he had what's supposed to
culminate from that just sharing the
household sharing bodies with each other
what's deeper than that yeah maybe
kids could be kids are a product of it
and Thomas earth thought that
procreation was a central part of it of
marriage kids driving let's say the
marriage doesn't actually produce any
any kids is it is it a true marriage I
think yes yeah yeah and a connection
that can't be replaced right where you
get to know the other person as who they
are and then that's not okay for sex
right a lot of all the other you know
companions but they're all connected so
yeah you know really good marriage give
them sort of deepening of the
relationship and that's what we call
conjugal love where some people call
that intimacy well you have to have a
body to do that does that mean that the
body is the primary good thing no that
intimacy with respect to marriage
intimacy that's not reducible cuz that
person's body to the chamber time I
think that's one way to tell whether a
marriage is based on appearances
still attractive to their mate mates
going to have them around not that it
was all based on just a lot
he says secondly because granted at the
end of man's will unreasonably the
preservation of the human beings being
it can't be said that the end of the
person has some good of the body we
actually have a higher dimension to us
this is where ever we get to I should
publish it book isn't so higher the body
we have a higher dimension to us than
just a body we have a soul and our soul
gives us reason than intellect
that's separates us from the rest of the
animals they're talking a lot about this
class that gives you a particular kind
of dignity a particular kind of work
maybe happiness has to be slide there
and before Thomas actually goes on but
he considers one other thing that kind
of bridges a gap between body and soul
pleasure couldn't plug in canvas
Aristotle thought you know this is a
view that actually has to be taken
seriously and some of the people that
you've studied this semester thought
that yeah that's that right the hedonist
have a curious erysipelas Bentham and
mill we looked at four different people
who said yeah happiness is pleasure or
the lack of pain Thomas says can it be
pleasure he says well let's think about
it two ways there's there's pleasures of
the body
there's pleasures of the soul why can't
it be pleasures of the body well again
this is where we get to what's
specifically about us what do we
experience bodily pleasures through that
which we have
animal nature dogs like chocolate right
that's what if it was chocolate because
it's got so much something you know
they'll leave it well they hate a German
Shepherd ones who actually like I had
all these chocolate bars of the front
away and said it's not to be from
Switzerland the dog I had like bits of
chocolate so I'd give me bits of it and
I didn't realize what I was doing was
actually showing him first of all where
the chocolate came from and then
teaching him that chocolate tastes great
and I came home work the next day and he
had actually taken it was nice he didn't
actually do all of it he took half of
the chocolate bars out of it and he'd
actually and torn them after his alive
and then even the whole bars of
chocolate so either the dog ate like
four my big chocolate bars
I hope that we can do that very quickly
I mean I could probably define that
would be a lot of chocolate for me but I
could probably manage it willing to bet
some of you might might be able to eat
that much chocolate at one sitting but
that's that's not happiness that's
that's gratifying us in a certain way
it's pleasure and that's good but it's
not satisfying deeper dimensions of us
things that have to do with the soul so
what about pleasures soul maybe those
could actually satisfies those they
actually do derive from what
specifically human think about learning
you know not everybody enjoys learning
every single thing but there's something
so good of the soul nearby and you take
pleasure that's more specifically if the
dog doesn't sit down and say I'm going
to study this today we'll just go out
you know eat something or chase
something or act on an incidence and we
have delight that arises from this we
feel a sense of the goodness of the
objects and it's different than
chocolate chocolate you know there's a
little aftertaste after done eating it
with any drink some water now your
chocolate enjoyment is gone all right
may there may be it satisfied some
hunger but won't be able to do that just
as well maybe even better because the
open you know fiver to stick with you
right
what about learning something we're what
about the joys of the new experience of
listening to the music or friendship the
joys of experience in friendship really
deep lasting friendship those are those
are pleasures on the soul you take
delight in it
Papa says well either those would be the
perfect good happiness itself or they
would be some sort of imperfect good a
share of happiness an Aries thing yeah
this is really important we want to feel
pleasure in this whole but what do we
feel pleasure about the enjoyment of
some sort of good so whatever good it is
that we're enjoying if anything's going
to be a candidate for happiness
it's got to be death not just the
pleasure itself so now I'm going to
finally move to the highest points at
least that we're capable of by ourselves
what about some good of the soul what
are good things in your cells
- personality soul is to theological for
you what would you describe as being
more you something that you can actually
I mean earlier we talked about
accomplishments like a lot of us have
accomplished a great deal just to even
get a chance to be here at Mars yeah the
good thing is basically would be your
intent behind that are you there just so
you could get the degree or are you
proud of the fact that you're here now
you have the opportunity to learn and
gain this knowledge okay by being here
at Marist oh it's something like that
you can be proud of so your intent
behind that of the things that you do
yeah so well mrs. hansal constant what
holds things constant
you know reading virtuous right and
those do have to do with your intent and
they often have to do with your emotions
also to do with what you actually do and
they have to do with the kind of
character that
to display those are goods in your
stroller in your personality maybe that
could be the be-all and end-all
ourselves same thing for something
virtuous activity you know there are
other things you need like friends but
those are just extra stuff it's really
vicious activity what else is there any
is there any other candidates for great
things that's the action plan we didn't
talk about this when we talked about
aerosol there's a little detour that we
didn't follow up we talked about the
more contemporary life what are you
actually trying to attain your other
bears
besides friendships besides getting a
job later on it's good
I would somebody hiding your diploma
certification what are you supposed to
be able to put on the table skills yeah
skills knowledge the sort of things that
you build into yourself intellectual
virtues politics yeah what you know what
you've mastered or you can actually talk
about competently but you can judge well
when you also know how to research more
to find out the things you don't know
that's part of it of you
that's established inside of you that's
why we can't just replace it with a
robot or a computer good
we don't need you write this very harsh
to say it that's that's the wind
marketplace national works
we don't have elevator operators that
really replace the things that you have
intellectual accomplishments those are
something very good now Thomas says
something interesting here he says these
are actually very could those be our
last end could those be the final goal
could those be the things that actually
make us fully happen you can think about
your own experience in those of others
can you actually be verge of us and be
you know very wise or intelligent and
not be fully had to be lacking something
you can't there can't still be something
missing he says that if we speak of
man's last end it's impossible for that
to be the soul itself for something
belonging to why well whether it's the
power and habit or an act you have to
fulfill our desires completely full he
says human the appetite otherwise the
wills for the universal good the
greatest good here's where we get into a
theological dimension if God exists then
radically changes everything
the whole perspective
nothing could be fully good if this is
left out of the picture there would
always be something lacking even if you
were you know gifted intellectually if
you developed all of your gifts and you
were a great person morally and you
actually knew it and you could look at
yourself and even if you threw it all
the other thing well pleasure Goodbody
reputation all those sorts of things
there would still be something Latin so
we could come this is a theological
point of view right Augustine says our
hearts are restless until they arrested
you and what you're talking about God if
there is a God if there is something
divine but there is something
transcendent to human beings something
that is not just roof you know of this
world I don't mean transcendent in the
sense of like being bigger than us like
an organization or a nation or something
like that I've genuinely transcendent
then that would actually be the good
that would be the highest good and
lacking that all the other stuff would
in some ways be empty buts not the say
that these aren't good they're just not
completeness it wouldn't totally
satisfied a person that's promises point
we're actually going to have to skip
through this very quickly let me just
get out a few points before we we had so
I mean the very last question in this
very less particle in this question
he says it's impossible for any created
good to constitute human happiness
happiness is the perfect good which
walls the appetite all together
otherwise it wouldn't be
last death is something yet remain to be
desired the object of the will is the
universal good
so it's evident that nothing candle all
that human as well save the University
this is not to be found in any creature
and it created the angle because they're
all did but in God alone because every
other creature every creatures art has
goodness by participation so what would
that could be I mean it's one thing to
say okay God the good god is good should
be you know looking for God or stuff
like that that's kind of big isn't it I
mean that may have actually turned you
off when people said stuff like that to
you before I don't turn me off said it
to be told things sort of platitudes
like that time a special place he says
what it means there's two real important
things be it says what this really means
is one getting to see the divine essence
getting to see what God is face-to-face
not just like you know having a Bible
you know singing songs about Jesus or
things like that but actually getting to
see the thing and understand it as best
as we can we're limited creatures exist
the other thing is actually this is
worried exactly like moral virtue having
rectitude of will which means having all
of the things about us be directed in
the right ways Thomas thinks that if you
actually did see God face to face you
would want everything
to be squared away you would want
everything to be fixed all the damaged
parts everything that could have gone
wrong you'd want it then fixed in one
way or another to them altered for the
good so that you could actually
participate in the relationship it's one
thing to like get a look at somebody who
you love from afar and to admire them
it's a very different thing to actually
be in a relationship with them it's
enough to have a back and forth
communication this is this is gonna be a
very silly example that I mean ahead
with our very silly analogy Thomas
doesn't want everybody to be gods
starters you know what's a stalker like
a stalker is somebody who admires from
afar and you know I was obsessed with
somebody because because you know
there's something attractive about that
person and they you know they can't get
away from so they follow them around and
they you know they check on Facebook
they get their phone number and they you
know maybe they videotape them or
something like that that would be sort
of like knowing God without being in
relationship with God being like a
stalker you'd actually want to be in
relationship having back and forth in
order to do that Thomas thinks you would
actually have to be a good person you
would actually have to try to work on
the parts of yourself that are damaged
or flaw
now can this be realized in this life
not fully Thomas talks about that one of
these articles for Thomas Aquinas true
happiness lies not in this life we can
participate
like it actually lies in the next life
so again very Theological dimension
there that again many of you may have a
hard time buying so the last thing I'm
going to say is it's not really a matter
at least as far as this class because of
whether you agree with Thomas or even
agree with his starting points it's it's
a matter trying to understand